- So Doctor Simone Gold,
who is perhaps most famous
for participating in
the January 6th riots,
tells Mike Lindell that she's forming
the Legal Eagle Dream
Team to end all lockdowns
and the emergency use authorizations.
- And the Legal Eagle Dream Team consists
of warrior attorneys who
plan to bring lawsuits,
really across the country.
- Thanks to Patriot Takes
for the heads up on this one.
Now, first of all,
regarding her forming the
Legal Eagle Dream Team, rude.
And second of all, this
is not going to work.
There's a long line of cases
that basically allow states
and the federal government
to engage in lockdowns
related to pandemics.
It goes back hundreds of years
to the founding of our country.
We've covered this a lot on this channel.
But efforts to claim that
these laws are illegal,
they rarely work, and I
don't think this effort
is going to work either.
Now, whether I should sue
for trademark infringement,
well, that's another matter entirely.
So I might see her in court.